[Applause]
all right
this is the hottest Sports ticket in
China right now thousands of people from
across the country are cramming into an
outdoor stadium to watch this Grassroots
basketball league that's become a
nationwide phenomenon
we travel to a remote Mountain Village
in the country's Southwest the hometown
of China's answer to the NBA
the scene here Rivals what you'll see in
a lot of pro basketball games all across
China
[Music]
or the village Basketball Association
provides a window into trans passion for
the American Sport and has even
attracted the attention of professional
NBA stars
[Music]
these amateur games which run well into
the night
have blown up on social media in China
we look at how this basketball court has
become one of the few places where the
US and China amid spiraling relations
share a common ground
[Music]
Taipan Village is a small rural Village
of just 1 200 people in one of China's
poorest provinces guay Joe
there's no reason why you ever would
have heard of this Village and in fact
most Chinese people had never heard of
it until a couple of weeks or months ago
and now it's become one of the hottest
spots in China because of the tunbie
and it's really taken off here in China
not just in this Village here but all
across this country at 1.4 billion
people in Beijing and Shanghai all the
big cities have been tuning in watching
live streams on the Chinese version of
tick tock and it's really gone viral
one of the things that makes this tunbie
so special is that none of these players
are professional but what's so good
about them and what do people love it's
happened here
another reason that the tunbie stands
out is it breaks the norm in China's
top-down Sports system
you have a system that identifies
athletes of Promise early on in their
lives and nurtures them through the
system often pays for their training
this is totally different what you see
here this is Amateur Basketball
and part of the appeal here not just the
basketball it's about the whole festival
atmosphere here it's like a big karaoke
night they're doing singing There's
dancing there's games there's all sorts
of fun and festivities
[Music]
the electric atmosphere here it's even
attracted some attention in the NBA
Jimmy Butler of Miami Heat fresh off his
NBA Finals appearance was here to take
in the matches himself if he put on a
traditional ethnic minority outfit and
uh took the mic at the center of the
stage
[Music]
[Applause]
seven Marbury a former NBA star now
coaching in China's professional League
visited Taipan Village recently to draw
attention to the potential Talent
playing here in the countryside
this can possibly open up opportunities
for players who do play in the village
league for them to be able to get looked
at it you need to be able to play
professionally basketball in China
basketball is one of those
quintessentially American Sports
and this is a time of U.S China tensions
and yet you don't feel that at all
people here love the NBA
[Applause]
amid Rising geopolitical tensions this
basketball court in Taipan Village
remains a rare Arena of consensus for
the two superpowers
[Applause]
foreign